- Is it gonna explode?
Oh, (beep).
Zoya!
Hi, I'm Alex, and today I'm
joined by a very special guest,
my girlfriend.
- Hi, I'm Zoya.
- And today we're gonna be swapping
some of our favorite snacks.
I actually brought some
of my favorite snacks from my childhood.
- I also brought snacks from my childhood
but they kind of carried
over into adulthood as well.
- After each round, we'll decide
if we wanna keep our snacks or swap them.
Well, let's get snacking.
Here we are with snack number one.
Are you ready?
- Are you ready?
- I guess.
- All right.
- Tada!
- This is called an It's-it
and it is a legend of San Francisco.
I'm from Northern California.
It was made in 1928
and it's just a staple
of San Francisco history.
What did you bring?
- Mine was probably around before 1928
because it's dried mulberries.
Persians are huge fans of dried fruit,
but nothing is as common
as dried mulberries
and we call them toot.
- Toot!
- That's so cute.
Let's start with mine since it's ice cream
so it might melt.
I think you're really gonna like this
because it's actually two oatmeal cookies.
- I do like oatmeal cookies.
- Sandwiched
with ice cream in the middle
and then dipped in chocolate.
- Okay, cheers.
- Cheers.
- It's a little hard.
- It's-it!
- Is it it?
It's something.
I don't know.
- It's okay.
I feel like I remember them
being better than this.
Back in the 1928s!
Probably was it in 1928.
(Alex laughs)
- But as a kid, this was so delicious.
- It was it.
- Now it's, is it?
- Very cute, good job San Francisco, 1928.
- Time for the toot.
- But we usually eat them with tea.
Cheers to toot.
- Toot.
- It's kind of like a raisin.
I don't love raisins.
- It's not really like a raisin.
Maybe you could put the
mulberries in your sandwich.
That would help it be edible.
- It's good, they're good.
Would I keep my snack
or swap it for yours?
It's-it was okay
but I think I'd rather have the mulberries
just 'cause these would
just take up freezer space
in my house.
- I would keep my own
just because there's very
limited freezer space,
so if it's gonna be an ice cream,
it's gotta be the best.
- On to the next round.
Let's see what we're snacking on next.
Woo, both drinks!
- Is that Capri Sun?
- Of course it's Capri Sun.
What flavor?
- The beverage of our childhood.
Look at this pouch.
Strawberry-kiwi is the one we have.
These were so iconic.
Had them after every soccer game.
Before every soccer,
what kind of parenting style is that?
[Producer] Do you think
it'd be a good mixer?
Wow, I have not thought about that.
- Maybe punch a hole,
empty some of it out,
pour in some happy juice,
seal it back up.
- Happy juice.
This would be a great mixer.
- I brought something
that I don't wanna mix
with alcohol at all.
This is called doogh,
it's a Persian yogurt soda.
Usually you drink it with
meals or sometimes by itself.
as I say this out loud,
I realize maybe it sounds
a little different,
but it is liquified yogurt,
and this one in particular
is a mint flavor as well.
And then it's carbonated.
- I'm down,
that sounds kind of good, interesting.
Way different than a Capri Sun.
All right, let's swap.
- Sometimes at the very bottom,
the yogurt will collect,
so you wanna give it like a
good shake before you open it?
- It's carbonated.
Is it gonna explode?
Oh, (beep).
Zoya!
It smells like yogurt.
Really salty.
I could see it being
really refreshing yogurt,
a little bit sweet
and I even like the mint
but it is so salty that
it's a little hard.
- Yeah, this one's pretty salty.
- Salty.
I actually don't know when
last time I had Capri Sun was.
- There you go, look at that.
- Oh my God.
That is exactly like I
remember it, is so sweet.
- Oh my God.
Maybe we should mix the two.
- No.
- It's clear.
It is clear.
- Look at that.
- It's bubbling up.
Maybe this is like a reaction
like Mentos and Coke.
No.
- It seemed like a terrible idea,
but I wanted you to go through with it
so I could see how.
- Well, I did.
Are you gonna try it?
- Absolutely not.
- Actually, I don't want
either of these snacks.
I'm gonna swap 'em both.
- If I had to pick one, I'd keep the dough
because at least it's interesting
but maybe just a different flavor.
- Well, let's see what's next
as I clean this up.
It's time for snack number three.
Ready?
- I'm ready.
- Set, go.
Woo!
I'm assuming you've had
Swedish Fish before.
- I think once.
- Once?
- Yeah.
- I love Swedish Fish.
They're just sweet, fruity, sourish candy.
Red is the best flavor
so they sell them in pack of red.
- I brought a small piece of lavashak,
which is Persian fruit leather.
This one is pomegranate flavor.
I did you a favor and brought
you a bite size piece.
Traditionally it comes on
this long sheet, basically,
wedged between plastic
and you have to peel the plastic
- Like a fruit roll-up.
- Yes, but those are
designed for the plastic
to come off,
whereas lavashack plastic,
just doesn't come off
so you'll inevitably
eat some of the plastic.
- Oh, my God.
- I remember Swedish
Fish has multiple colors.
- [Producer] I don't remember them being-
- Are you serious?
- [Producer] Yeah.
- Guys, I swear.
Please let me know.
Comment below if you guys remember
that Swedish Fish were multicolored.
Smells like soap.
- Oh, my God.
- Mm, they're so good.
I love the texture of them.
Not as hard as a gummy bear.
- You like these?
- Yeah.
- Oh.
- You don't like 'em?
- No, it kind of has a licorice taste
- I'm not getting that.
Let's try yours because I have a feeling
you're complaining about this
getting stuck in your teeth,
I have a feeling that this
is going to get stuck in my teeth.
- It will get stuck in your teeth.
- Why is everything so salty?
Very sour.
I don't hate it.
I like it.
I would say it tastes
more natural than this.
Now, trying this,
it tastes a little bit chemically.
Honestly, it might be
good to combine them.
- Do it.
I'm gonna try it too.
- Mm, that is good.
- That's delicious.
- It's really good.
We've completely changed
the frame of this video
into just combining snacks
together and see if they work.
All you have to do is take
your little Swedish Fish
put some lavashack on there.
You got yourself a great snack.
I guess this means we'll take both.
We'll keep and we'll swap.
We are ready for our final snack.
Are you ready?
- I think so.
Woo!
Zoya, have you had these before?
York peppermint patties.
- I don't think I've ever had.
- These are like a love-hate for me.
Definitely a ton of nostalgia.
I feel like I would eat these
at my grandparents' house.
They hold a lot of memories.
- I brought gaz.
- So you brought a toot and a gaz.
- Gaz has been around for a long time
and it's a very traditional Persian snack.
It's a nougat with pistachios inside.
- That sounds good to me.
- I think you're gonna
like this one a lot.
Let me break this puppy open.
- Cheers.
- Oh.
- It's like toothpaste.
- Literally tastes like
toothpaste and chocolate,
my favorite combination.
This is odd.
- I do like mint and
I like mint chocolate,
but this ain't it.
This ain't it.
- This ain't it.
- Let me try yours.
I'm excited for this one.
My mouth is overpowered by mint flavor.
It looks like a marshmallow.
Mmm, that's yummy.
Chewy, soft, not too sweet.
The nuts are a nice touch.
Am I getting a little bit of rosewater?
- You might.
- It's a classic Persian thing, huh?
- Rosewater in everything.
Gaz.
- You had me at gaz.
- I'm definitely swapping
my York for the gaz.
- I'm gonna keep my gaz as
much as I loved the York.
- And there you have it.
Zoya, thank you so much
for bringing some really delicious snacks.
- You're welcome.
Thank you for bringing snacks.
- Maybe we'll do this again.
- Maybe not.
- Until next time.
If you want a real snack,
follow me on Instagram, majortraeger.
- And if you want an even better snack,
you can follow me @zoyaroya.
- Bye.
(upbeat jazzy music)